[موسيقى]
ونحييكم الى التفاصيل قالت هيئه البث
الاسرائيليه الرسميه كان ان الاداره
الامريكيه اوضحت سنه ياهو ان هناك خطين
احمرين يجب على حكومته عدم تجاوزهما وهما
ضم مناطق منظفه الغربيه الى اسرائيل
وتغيير الوضع القائم في المسجد الاقصى
وقالت كان ان ال- امريكا اوضحت لاسرائيل
ان اي عمليه النظام الاراضي في الضفه او
تغيير الوضع الراهن في المسجد الاقصى
بمثابه خط احمر واشار الجهات امريكيه في
محادثات مع مقربين من رئيس الوزراء
المكلفه
الى ان الحوار تركز بين البلدين على قضايا
تتعلق بالاستقطان قد ياتي ذلك على حساب
المساعي لمكافحه ايراني واوضح المسؤولون
الامريكيون ان اداره بيضا حذرت من انشغال
الحكومه القادمه بتبني سياسه المتطرفه
تجاه القضيه الفلسطينيه سيقلص من قدره
الولايات المتحده على التعاون معها في
مجال مواجهه البرنامج النووي الايراني»
[موسيقى]
ونقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من القدس
الدوليه اهلا بكم يسمحلي ان ابدا من القدس
معك يا سيد شلومو سيد شلومو قبل الحديث عن
العلاقات او مستقبل العلاقات الثنائيه
الاسرائيليه الامريكيه هل يمكن القول بان
نتنياهو ورط نفسه بتحالفه مع اليمين
المتطرف
القدر المال
ولكن هو يحاول الان بقدر المستطاع الخروج
من هذه الورطه
الاتفاقات المفصله وايضا جميع الاطراف
وسائق الاداره الامريكيه بانه هو واحد بقى
له كود سيكون المسؤول الاول عن توجيه
السياسه الاسرائيليه ولا خطر على انحدا
السياسه الاسرائيليه
والخضوع للاهتزاز السياسي
للاحزاب المتدينا ولا احزان اليمن
ولكن همم هذه الرسائل هي الرسائل تمهيديه
لطلب الاداره الامريكيه بعدم التسرع في
اتخاذ موقف متشدد الاذاعه الحكومه الجديده
وعدم الحكم عليها او على على اعضاء
الوزاره او وهذه تصريحات في الواقع
تلقفتها الجهه الامريكيه دكتور
تحدث تقريبا في نفس هذا الاطار وقال باننا
سنحكم على عمل الحكومه ولا نحكم على
الاشخاص
المكونين لهذه الحكومه ولكن عندما ندقق في
هذه الحكومه سنرى بان هناك اسماء من
اليمين المتطرف همم ونذرك همم
ميولهم على الاقل همم
نتحدث عن بن غفير همم والكل يعرف بانه من
بين الاسماء المؤيدين
او نظام الدفع الغربيه وهي من النقاط ومن
الخطوط الحمر التي وضعتها واشنطن همم فكيف
يمكن ان يكون هناك تعامل بين هذه الاداره
وبين اسرائيل بمثل هكذا اسماء وبمثل هكذا
نزعت متطرفه
[موسيقى]
يمكن ان نتحدث عن ذلك بالتفصيل اكثر
فالاداره ترى همم لديها مخاوف وعبر عن ذلك
عدد من المسؤولين الامريكيين من السياسات
التي قد تتبناها هذه الحكومه الجديده
وخاصه تضم شخصين من اكثر الشخصيات التطرفا
همم
مثل بين كبير
همم وهما يمنحوا ما نتنياهو على الاقل كما
ذكر بعض وسائل الاعلام همم صلاحيات واسعه
في الضفه الغربيه وايضا كان هناك باء عن
النبي كبير قد يقوم بزياره الى الاقصى كل
هذه الاماكن المقدسه في القدس تقع تحت
سيطره اسرائيل وهذه اقوى همم الاداره
وازعجت همم عدد من السياسيين الامريكيين
ولكن
نعم في في البيت الابيض
وصف بانه كثير الحساسيه لمناقشه هذا
الموضوع وكيفيه تعامل الاداره الامريكيه
مع الحكومه الاسرائيليه وفعلا كان هناك
اصوات متباينه الى حد ما لم يتخذ قرار
نهائي ولكن كان هناك موقف تحذيري اشار
اليه وزير الخارجيه في ما يتعلق بما تفضلت
وذكرته عليه وهو ضم ناطق جديده موضوع همم
الاقصى وايضا كان هناك حديث همم حول همم
قيام اسرائيل وقوات كانت حتى المستوطنين
بانه ياكل البيوت الفلسطينيه همم وهذه
ايضا مزعجه خاصه في هذا الوقت لان القارئ
يتخوف من تداعيات قد تكون اثقل يقول البعض
بان همم بن غفير وهمم اسمه تريتش همم هم
من مؤيدين مثلا الاختيالات فيتخوفها لبعض
بان تفتح صفحه جديده من الاختيالات اليوم
كذلك من المؤيدين لمنع الزيارات في السجون
وبالتالي سيد شلومو ااه كيف يمكن ان يقنع
نتنياهو الاداره الامريكيه بانها حكومه او
بان حكومه ستكون حكومه معتدله كما كان
يروج دائما سيكون صعب
مؤهلات
ومعروف بانه ذو موروناسيه
وتاكلهم سياسي همم سيحاول بكل قواه
استخلاص العبر في العلاقات الاقتصاديه
الامريكيه وعدم الوقوع في نفس الخلافات
التباينات التي كانت في عهد الرئيس الاسبق
اوباما واعتقد ايضا بان هو هذا هو ايضا
العبره الامريكيه عبره الرئيسه بين شخصيا
من العلاقات المستقبل
مثاليه حتى وان كانت علاقته في البدايه في
الثمانينات لما كان الاول همم
يشتغل في السفاره الاسرائيليه في واشنطن
والثاني كان سنتر شاب كانت جيده ولكن هناك
مراحل شهيده طرفا مراحل همم من التشنج همم
فالبعض يقول بان وكان هذه الخطوه ستكون
خطوه همم بدايه الخلافات بين الجهتين هل
هذا وارد
هذا بارد
بانه سيحاول التنفين الاسرائيلي والامريكا
لحد سواء في القران مع الرئيس بعد تشكيل
الحكومه في وضع اسس للتعامل المشترك في
مناقشه المواضيع المتباينه عليها داخل
الغرف المغلقه وليس همم في وسائل الاعلام
كما كان في عهدائهم ايضا حصر المواضيع
المتباينه عليها واجاد قاعده متفق عليها
خاصه في المواضيع همم ايرانيه والموضوع
الفلسطيني
[موسيقى]
الولايات المتحده في الشرق الاوسط ولذلك
سيحافظ الطرفين على حد سواء الحفاظ على
هذه العلاقات على وتيره الساخنه ودافئه
وموتقاربه من العلاقات بالرغمه من
الخلافات ولكن بين الاصدقاء هناك خلافات
ولا يمكن تسميتها طيب هل يمكن ان يكون هذا
هذه المحاولات
هذه المحاولات لطم انا الاداره الامريكيه
هل يمكن ان تكون همم مقنعه للجانب
الامريكي مقنعه لبايدا لان البعض يتحدث عن
ان قطيعه في الافق قد تشهد هذه العلاقات
اعتقد انه المبكر كثيرا الله القول بانه
ستكون هناك قطيعه وان كان هناك فالمي بعض
التلميحات مثلا وزير الخارجيه قال ان
الاداره الامريكيه ستتعامل ليس مع الاشخاص
في حكومه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه الجديده وتقرر موقفها
بناءا على هويه ومواقف هؤلاء الاشخاص ولا
على السياسه
للاداره مجال للمناره او هامش للذهاب
بالاتجاهين اتجاه من ناحيه احتمال تبني
موقف اكثر يتشددا ومن اتجاه الاداره
الاسرائيليه ومن ناحيه اخرى يمكن ايضا ان
يسمح للاداره بان تستمر في سياستها من
ناحيه توجه بعض الانتقادات
صحيح ولكن بمعرفتنا بالاشخاص خاصه بن
غفيرتهم المعروفون على الاقل
تصريحاتهم وحتى بطريقتهم التي يصفها البعض
بالعنيفه همم في حتي حديثهم عن مواضيع
يوميه همم فبالتالي هل يصدق الجانب
الامريكي ان تكون هذه الحكومه حكومه
معتدله كما يريد ان يروج لها نتانيا
هذه هي المساله ان هناك الان اصوات حتى
داخل الاداره الامريكيه بدات تشعر
بتداعيات هذه المواقف وان هذه المواقف
وهذا التحالف داخل الحكومه الاسرائيليه قد
يضع ضغوط ليس فقط على الحكومه الاسرائيليه
ضغوط على الاداره الامريكيه لعده اسباب
وهذه الاسباب بين هناك تحولات في الراي
العام الامريكي بدانا نراها خلال السنتين
الماضيتين بدانا نرى منظمات حقوق انسان
تصرف اسرائيل بانه حكومه
ثلاث تقارير من الامم المتحده ال- ال-
المؤسسات المختصه بمناقشه قضايا
الشرق الاوسط وقضاء اللاجئين وقضايا حقوق
الانسان تصرف اسرائيل بان حكومه فصل اوصري
راينا عدت كنائس مسيحيه تفعل ذلك راينا
شباب يهودي ينتقلوا اسرائيل ويسكوها ما
بينهم صحفيين يهود امريكيين وبالتالي هذا
من ناحيه من ناحيه اخرى بدانا نسمع اصوات
تقول ايضا ان الولايات المتحده تتبنى
مواقف متشدده اوكرانيا فتهم الروسيه بضم
الاراضي وان هذا الضم
ينتهك القانون الدولي همم وبالتالي فانه
وهو غير مقبول ولذلك في الولايات المتحده
تقدم الخلفاءها يقدم يجب ان يقدم كل هذه
المساعدات ولكن في نفس الوقت لا نسمع اي
صوت بالنسبه للضمه الاسرائيلي ان كان في
القدس او في في الضفه الغربي
عن ان المجال المفتوح في الفتره القادمه
لمتابعه عمليه الضم طيب لما حظرتك حدث سيد
شلونه عن انا نتنياه سيعمل على ان تكون
هذه الحكومه حكومه متوازنه هنا البعض
سيجيب بان هؤلاء الاشخاص الذين نتحدث عنهم
لن نتحدث فقط عن يمين متطرف ولكن نتحدث عن
اشخاص ندرك طريقه تعاملهم مع الملفات فكيف
لي نتنيه التسريبات على الاقل تتحدث عن ان
نتنياهو سلمهم وزاره البناء في الحسابات
قبل الاعلان عن التشكيل النهائي الوزاره
وزاره الاسكان والبناء وذرتين او لجنتين
في وزاره الداخليه وهما يدافعان عن منطقه
همم استمراريه الظن همم كيف سيتتصرف
نتنياهو في الداخل وهل بمقدوره اساسا ان
يضبط الامور
نعم هذا ما
يتعدى اذا اخذنا موضوع الضمه في هذه هي
طموحات لليمين والمتدينين والمتشددين ولكن
هي ستظل بمثابه احلام وطموحات لان العمل
الطريقه المفصله والتنفيذيه التنفيذيه
لتطبيق الضم
واخراج هذه الفكره وهذا الطموحات الى حيث
التنفيذ ستكون بعيده عن التنفيذ لان
صلاحيات ستكون بايدي نت اليوم فقط وليس
بايدي الوزراء عندما تفضلت واذا فضلتي
بالرغم بما انهم سيتمتعون بالميزانيات
لمساواه ما يسمونه بمساواه الحقوق المدنيه
للمستوطنين في الضفه الغربيه مع المواطنين
الايطاليين في داخل القبله اه لذلك كل هذا
هي بمثابه وعود همم وعود انتخابيه ولكن هم
يطالبون ويطالبون حتى بمعامله اليهود
الاسرائيليين بطريقه مختلفه عن
الاسرائيليين العرب هذه كيف سيحلها
نتنياهو
الشرع الاسرائيلي والمجتمع الاسرائيلي ككل
وايضا دورا المعارضه ستقف بالمرصاد ايضا
من بين انصار نتنياهو وانصار الكود
سيواردون التمييز لان هذا سيكون بمثابه
ضربه للمجتمع الاسرائيلي ككل ولا سمعه
اسرائيل الدوليه واعتقد ان هناك ادنى
المشترك اسرائيلي داخلي
امكانيه للتمييز تحسبا للوضع حتى الفكره
دكتور باختصار انت كرامه فلا الامور ما
اهم الملفات التي يمكن ان يضغط بها بيضا
على هذه الحكومه
فعلا الرئيس بعد ان يستطيع ان يضغط وهناك
ايضا موقف تتبناه يعود الى اداره اوباما
عندما زار نتنياهو الولايات المتحده تحدث
الى الكونجرس دون معرفه الرئيس مسبقا
للرئيس الامريكي بذلك الوقت وهذه مساله لم
يسع كثيرون هناك طبعا احتمال الضغط
السياسي والاقتصادي على على اسرائيل ولكن
اعتقد ان في نفس الوقت الذي نرى اصوات
متزايده تنتقل السياسه الاسرائيليه ونرى
قلق من داخل الاداره حيث عقد اجتماع لاول
مره في مجلس الامن القومي وناقشه عده
قضايا موضوع تعامل الاسرائيلي على الاقل
في الداخل بما فيها الفلسطينيين طبعا
العرب الذين ضمن الخط الاخضر
الغربيه وحقوق الانسان هذه قضايا مهمه
عليها
مع النبي تحالف كذلك لانه اعتقد حسابين
يلزمها طرف اخر يتحالف معه سيكون طرف ااا
يميني كذلك سنتابع هذه التفاصيل او شكرا
لكم جزيلا الشكر منه واشنطن دكتور ادم
غريب الاستاذ في العلاقه الدوليه ومن
القدس